but a surrogate process Kim knows it's
really hard for me what does that mean
she had a really hard time accepting the
whole process got it so mine it's really
the worst because Khloe Kardashian keeps
it real about the challenges of
welcoming a baby via surrogacy I'm gonna
figure it all out I promise you Coco
opens up about struggling to bond with
her newborn son on the season 3 premiere
of Hulu's the Kardashians during a chat
with her sister Kim and Scott Disick I
do think that there is a difference when
the baby is in your belly
the baby actually feels your real heart
Kim who shares four children with her ex
Kanye West carried her two eldest
children North and saint but used a
surrogate with her younger kids Chicago
and Psalm after having difficult
pregnancies I think it's so much harder
to go through it this way because you're
not really in control and knowing that I
was able to carry my first two babies
and not you know my baby now that is
hard for me as for Chloe she shares her
five-year-old daughter true and her
nine-month-old son with her ex Tristan
Thompson the on-again off-again couple
split in December 2021 after news broke
that Tristan cheated on Chloe and
fathered a child with another woman I
was definitely very angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled the Revelation came just days
after Chloe claimed Tristan encouraged
her to do an embryo transfer to have a
second child together via surrogate I
definitely like buried my head in the
sand during that pregnancy that I didn't
digest what was happening and so I think
when I went to the hospital I really
think that was the first time that
really registered and has nothing to do
with the baby I definitely was in a
State of Shock I think from my entire
experience
in general of course cameras were
rolling as the good American founder
welcomed her baby boy to the world I've
been on the fence about having Tristan
come to the hospital or not I think that
you have a real insight into what the
girls are doing not only you know what
you see in the press or whatever but
what's really happening behind the
scenes I felt really guilty that like
this woman just had my baby and you're
just I take the baby and then I go to
another room and you're sort of
separated like I felt it's such a
transactional experience because it's
not about him
I wish someone was honest about
surrogacy
and the difference of it but it doesn't
mean it's bad or good it's still great
it's just very different and all that
Echoes what Kim had to say about her
experience with surrogacy back in 2017.
I hated being pregnant but I still even
in how much I hated it if I could do it
myself I would have preferred that so
that's a little like that inner
struggles kind of hard as for Chloe's
relationship with Tristan despite being
broken up she has publicly shown her
support for the NBA Pro and remains
focused on raising their kids everyone
has to handle their co-parenting
situation in their own style it's hard
work for all parties it's a beautiful
thing to get along with each other and
for your kids to see that and something
tells us Chloe will keep us up to speed
on her love life motherhood and all
things in between on the famous fam's
reality show I wish I could tell you
this is going to be a mild relaxing
green season
it's not